[Music]
hello friends what a blessing to be with
you again here in our program
i'd like to know
i am daniel miranda an associate speaker
for
some tv and some tv latino
and i have with me my dear fellow
associate speaker also ca
you are very familiar with him
and it is a blessing to be with him in
this program together
we have
interesting questions today to answer
and we want to encourage encourage you
again to send
your questions
we love to receive your questions
you can send them at
tv
at some tv.org
tv at some tv dot org
we'll be very happy
to receive your questions if you don't
get an answer soon
we promise you that we will answer them
today um
as i said we have very
good questions as always
and before we do that we want to ask
god's blessing
sia could you please open whipper my
pleasure to do so father god we thank
you for the blessings of study we thank
you for this opportunity to answer
questions from the word of god we thank
you that you have put your seal on your
word you honor your word above your name
that your word is the truth the whole
truth and nothing but the truth and if
we but follow your word
we will have have wisdom to make our way
in this wicked world and to prepare for
higher citizenship in the world which is
to come we praise you and we thank you
we ask that you may be the teacher
during this program in jesus name amen
amen amen
okay so we have a question from
jax
cover
and his question has to do with
the mark of the beast
whether we'll be forced to worship on
sunday or just rest on sunday so
he has a debate with a good friend
um
his friend
says that this the mark of the beast
is the enforcing
of sunday worship
but he believes
that um
is actually
actually his friend believes that it is
sunday rest but he believes that
it is sunday
worship so what does the bible and the
spirit of prophecy say about that
all right the
the contention here seems to be between
rest
and and worship worship is the mark of
the beast enforced by asking us excuse
me to rest
or
uh is worship the issue
now
in its broadest context
daniel the the issue
has always been worship correct when
when satan
uh
assaulted christ in the
wilderness after his 40 days of fasting
when he finished with the other games
and he got down to
what he was really about what he's
always wanted
he said
worship me i'll give you this which was
not his to give by the way
if you will worship me
when the woman at the well
talked with christ
christ said
it's not important if you worship in
samaria or in jerusalem on mount
garrison
or on the temple mount
what i need is spirit and truth in
worship that's what god is seeking for
when we uh go to revelation and we look
at revelation 14 to 3 and his messages
again
we we talk about coming out of babylon
we talk about other things but
the call is to worship him amen so
ultimately it's always about worship and
so
the the crux of this issue
uh is worship correct not just rest
worship because you can stay in bed
on a sunday and and comply if rest is
all you have to do yes but it's not just
rest
it's worship amen and that's what um
what we want yeah and you mentioned that
the the three angels messages we find
the contrast between
worshiping god first angel
calls us or invites us to worship god
the creator
but the third angel's message
warns us against worshiping the beast
the contention has to do with worship
now revelation 13 16
this is what the
image of the beast is going to do and he
had power to give life and to the image
of the beast that the image of the beast
should both speak and cause
that as many as would not worship the
image of the beast
should be killed so we see here again
the issue of worship yeah and it's cause
in other words forced
there is force
uh there
let me read a quote from the book
evangelism
actually this is taken from the great
carnivores in the original uh source we
see here
when sunday observance
shall be enforced by law
there is the word and the world shall be
enlightened concerning the obligation of
true sabbath
then whoever shall transgress the
command of god to obey a precept which
has no higher authority than that of
rome
will thereby honor poppery above god
that is i've got
my ipad open up to a very controversy
the exact same quote okay it's it's at
the point of time when sunday
uh worship is enforced
see right now it's it's it's it's
promoted but it's not enforced
when you
are forced to make the decision is when
you are forced to worship so that's when
the mark of the beast uh
is is pronounced because you're you're
forced to make a decision you can flow
back and forth now it's there's no
particular burden either way but when
it's in force then you've got to make a
decision because your life your liberty
your freedoms will be on the line and
that decision has to be made at that
time and even goes beyond there's
another quote here from maranatha
page 177
and this is from june 18
and this says
at present
sunday keeping is not the test
the time will come when men will not
only forbid sunday work
that's one aspect
but they will try to force men to labor
on the sabbath and to subscribe to
sunday observance
or forfeit their freedom
and their lives
so it is not only about sunday rest but
sunday
of servants and we will not only be
forced to worship on sunday but we will
be
also forced to labor
on the sabbath yes
yes yes so you are you're not only
forced
to
worship and rest on sunday
you are also forced to work on saturday
right which is what the papacy has been
moving towards uh and her daughters for
a long long time there this reading i'm
looking at is really too long for us to
look at now but um if you look at the
great controversy
in the chapter liberty of conscience
threatened you will you will see these
quotes and and to get the whole history
you need to read the whole chapter so
you get the context for it but it's not
just rest
your friend is right but he's not right
enough because it is rest but it's not
just rest it's rest plus worship because
it's always been will always be about
worship
actually we're told that when the
powers that be
encourages not to work on sunday
that we should comply
and
just do missionary work on sunday and by
doing so we're not receiving the mark of
the beast yeah there was a time in the
uh
days of um a.t jones who went to
congress to advocate for us because
adventists were being thrown in jail
with with jews and other sabbath keepers
because of their activities on sunday
and uh it was it was said
with with some wisdom
you don't have to be out on your plow on
sunday you can do other kinds of things
to to not bring the wrath of the
government down upon you so let's be
wise let's be judicious but there's
going to come a time when you're going
to be forced to at that point you've got
to make a decision and that's when the
mark of the beast is brought out so very
good good question
excellent question
so next one this is a very interesting
question
um
again from our brother
jariella ponte figueroa from puerto rico
he says
to what extent
you shall not murder
can be taken
am i sinning or offending god if i kill
insects like mosquitoes and cockroaches
or other animals that generally speaking
are considered plagues
well if
if killing
cockroaches is a sin
then i am the chief of sinners
because
when i'm in in panama or or the tropics
and i see
anything with more than two legs
crawling i immediately go into execution
mode
and
i
i kill without with abandon and and i
have no regrets for it but you've got a
reading that i know you you registered
us before we we started that i think
really does a nice job so i want to go
to that because thou should not murder
was really designed for those for whom
christ died christ made a sacrifice for
human beings not for roaches not for
ants not for spiders not for bugs he
made it for human beings that he is
trying to redeem and believe me he's not
trying to dream roaches right
and et cetera et cetera et cetera but
let's go to their really danny because
it's very good yeah so i think that the
the quote is very straightforward this
quote
more than answers the question
this is from selected messages volume 3
page 329
yeah 329 and 330.
there are those who say that nothing
not even insects
should be killed
god has not entrusted any such message
to his people
it is possible to stretch the command
thou shalt not kill to any limit
this is exactly the same command that
the question is asking
but it is not according to sound
reasoning to do this
those who do it have not learned in the
school of christ
this earth has been cursed because of
sin
and
in these last days vermin of every kind
will multiply
these pests must be killed
or they will annoy and torment and even
kill us
and destroy the work of our hands and
the fruit of our land
in places there are ants or termites
which entirely destroy the woodwork of
houses
should not this be destroyed
for trees must be sprayed that the
insects which would spoil the fruit may
be killed
god has given us a part to act
and this part we must act with
faithfulness then we can leave the rest
with the lord and last paragraph
god has not has given no man the message
kill not
end or flee or mouth amen
troublesome and harmful insects and
reptiles we must guard against and
destroy
to preserve ourselves and our
possessions from harm even reptiles i
think of snake i think of
all these animals
and even if we do our best to externally
exterminate this pest
they will still multiply they won't
extinguish yes yes when that
that viper fastened itself on paul uh
on the i was a melitta
yes yes
and he shook it off in the fire
he didn't take it off and then say go
away and and then have a nice time he
shook it off in the fire you know
he made sure that was the last person
that that snake was going to bite so so
we know and i think you can you can kill
cucarachas and
other things you can stomp and spray and
to your heart's content you're not going
to wipe them out they multiply too fast
but if you just let them go
the other day i was i was uh was
watching something on pbs and they had
the woman with uh the the most filthy
house in great britain oh wow she hadn't
she hadn't taken out the garbage she
hadn't washed any dishes she hadn't
cleaned anything for about seven years
oh wow floor to ceiling garbage floor to
ceiling roaches floor to ceiling spiders
floor to ceiling other kind of bugs that
they didn't you couldn't even recognize
just floor to ceiling and she was living
in
uh
and sleeping in among all of these bugs
her legs were
covered with red swords from bed bugs
you know and uh and she wasn't an old
old woman maybe just in her 60s just
didn't feel like doing any cleaning so
they had taken over the place and uh
they had to
burn basically everything in the house
and then fumigate and fumigate and
fumikate and they still couldn't get it
couldn't get it clean so the idea that
you would never
step on a bug you would never rid
yourself of these things
it makes no sense and it's not it's
illogical it's unscriptural and it's not
it's not spiritual right yeah now um the
other side of the question is that at
the same time those creatures that god
created
and who are defenseless we should care
for them god gave us the stewardship to
care
for the animals we should not mistreat a
dog a cat or any other animal that
actually might be for our benefit we see
it for example balaam that was a
striking the donkey yes and god rebukes
him for that yes yes so god cares about
animals but i do not believe and i think
you might agree with me that god created
the roaches or or these insects
my thought is
roaches are after sin after the fall
exactly i don't think they came from the
hand of the second weaponized nature and
yes
we have these animals
so it is not a sin to kill them yeah it
is not illogical to think because
ellen white does tell us in story
redemption and and
the first chapters of of patriarchs and
prophets
that nature was cursed by sin thorns and
thistles were not in god's word no
creation so it is not illogical daniel
to believe that if
inanimate nature well plants really are
living things but if they change because
of sin that there are certain changes in
the animal world
because of sin you know you have you
have
spiders and these kind of things and i'm
i'm a bug i don't like bugs and my wife
will tell you if there's something
flying i will stay up all night till i
kill it you know and she's like just
just come to bed it'll you know just
take no i gotta the only only person
moving in this room is me and you that
wherever it is is not invited got to
take care of it and i will stay out
trying to take care of it i just don't
like
anything moving in the house but me and
my wife that's enough
yep not third party
it's a good question you know i wanted
to add here i was looking at you know
the lord says we also ought to be
careful um
not to do things that hasten our own
death
i was doing some research on fasting and
praying and i ran across the statement
illinois talks about a man who had
certain habits
uh private habits that were contributing
to his own demise
and she was saying he would go into the
woods
fast and pray for god to take these
habits from him and then he'd come out
and just resume them again
so let me read this so you get um just a
little context
this is kind of an adult subject so i'm
trying to be careful in the words that i
use this man
had gone so far he seemed to be left of
god
he would go into the woods and spend
days and nights in fasting and prayer
that he might overcome this great sin so
she calls it a great sin what he's doing
and then would return to his old habit
god did not hear his prayers he asked
god to do for him what he had in his
power to do for himself
uh he had vowed to god time and again
and had as often broken his vows and
given himself over to his own corrupt
lust so he was doing things that were
destroying his body destroying his
health
until god had left him to work
his own ruin
he has since died he was a self-murderer
she says the purity of heaven will never
be marred with his society now here's
the key
those who destroy themselves by their
own acts will never have eternal life so
that's any practice that you engage in
with shortens your lifespan
which endangers your health which makes
you of
less effect in the cause of god and
which is really self-murder so that
means drinking smoking staying up late
burning the candle at both ends all of
those things are shortening your life
eating foods that are
delatorious to your health
involving yourself in
social sexual psychological activities
that shorten your health
all of these things are are self-murder
they are
murdering
the body that christ died to save so we
have a
a spiritual responsibility as well as a
physical responsibility to do everything
that we do to the glory of god so if if
we cannot offer to god uh and it also
includes daniel the things we watch on
tv
the kinds of uh
uh
play and recreation we involve ourselves
in you know you have these people who
like to live dangerously jumping off of
cliffs climbing up the outside of
buildings unnecessarily uh putting their
lives at risk
for thrills
um and they're so those who live for
through so all of these things are are
they're just not convenient for the
christian to be involved and we should
be be very very careful i many years ago
had a motorcycle i had three
and as i got a little older my mother
said you know
you're a minister now and
that those bikes aren't helping you and
they're putting your life at risk and
you're going to be married soon
maybe you want to
put the bikes away you know and i got
the message
[Laughter]
star stop drive and i'm not saying
motorcycles are bad because i've been to
africa and other places where the
principal mode of transportation is is
motorcycles but for me c.a murray in the
united states with the traffic we have
here a motorcycle was not necessary and
it was bad recreation i have a very good
friend
jeffrey rodriguez his wife told him
don't get a motorcycle don't get a
motorcycle well he bought him because
he's old enough he had a good job and so
he shows i'm going to buy a motorcycle
he took it to church for a board meeting
coming back home he hit a open manhole
cover and
skinned up his knees broke bones uh
to this day when it gets ready to rain
outside he gets a pain in his shoulder
because they had to put metal in there
and you know this kind of thing uh he
should have known better yes so certain
things you can do you know
god gave you this life so that you can
give glory to him and if you cannot
offer him back to him in service maybe
you ought to just avoid that you don't
want to be a self-murderer by any act
that you do a good point yeah well said
yeah yeah now that wasn't in the
question that was just a little a little
change for your dollar you know
very good all right now you brought it
out
um so in the remaining of the time we
have here this is a very theological
question
in regards to the 400 years and 430
years prophecy time period this is from
nelson sparks
so genesis 15 13 and acts 7 6 says that
the israelites would spend 400 years in
egypt
but exodus 12 40 and 41
shows that the israelites stayed in
egypt 430 years
please explain discrepancy thank you
nelson from uganda
all right nelson from uganda i have been
to your country
and
have preached in kampala
the union office is right down the
street from a large mosque
as you look up the street at the top of
the hill there's this large mosque that
muammar gaddafi built
for
uganda and dedicated a very beautiful
building and then right down the street
is the union office and uh so i've been
to uh kampala very nice country very
nice people very very very fun fine
people
let's look at the text shall we i've got
genesis 15
and verse 13
and do you have acts 7 6
okay i will read
genesis 15
13 i'm reading from the new king james
as you turn to acts 7 6. then he said to
abram
know certainly that your descendants
will be strangers in a land that is not
theirs
and
will serve them and they will afflict
them
400 years
acts 7 6 says from the king james
version and god speaks on these wise
that his seed
should sojourn in a strange land and
that they should bring them into bondage
and entreat them
evil 400 years
all right
the thing that jumps out at me
first is the idea
that
these numbers are not given as precise
numbers for their for their uh bondage
in egypt
it's saying you're going to be in
this situation
for a number of years approximating 400
but there is no
statement that you're going to be in
exactly 400 years 400 more or less um
it's rounded off to 400 years
and we see this but in the fourth
generation they shall return here for
the iniquity of amorites uh is not yet
complete um so we're looking at uh
an approximate statement made by the
word of god that is not to be locked
down
like a prophetic thing
69 weeks
and seven weeks and you know that kind
of thing so we're not uh
62 weeks rather by the way not 16
[Laughter]
it's not an approximate prophetic
interpretation it is just a a statement
of what's going to happen to you
uh if you follow this course right
and also when you count
exactly the time when
the the
abraham seed was in egypt
that was actually around 250 years
uh 15 actually
so it was not actually the 400
years
we can
kind of approximate it as you said
from the time that abraham enters canaan
and count from there because actually in
acts 7 6 it says that
it doesn't specifically refer to egypt
but if it refers to a strange land
it includes both egypt and canaan
uh their sojourn in canaan and in egypt
approximately uh gives us
400 years now why 4 30 and why for 400
years
um
i believe
that
there is a slight difference because the
the 4 30 or the 400 years
is the time that they would be afflicted
and now that affliction the affliction
of abraham's seed began when ishmael
started to persecute isaac
isaac was around five years old and we
see that in genesis chapter 21 verse
verse five and then verse nine
that isaac is mocked
and from there
um
approximately
we cannot count exactly but from there
approximately to the time when moses
delivers the people of israel from egypt
we have uh 400 years so the 30 years are
the 30 years before the birth of isaac
abraham was 75 years old when he enters
canaan
and isaac was when he had isaac
uh 25 years had passed 25 years had
passed correct now isaac was 5 years old
so 30 years have passed and
that's uh the closest thing we can get
yes again um
and and well done
uh
we're not dealing with a hard period of
time we're dealing with an experience uh
there are other prophetic
interpretations uh utterances that lock
it you can you can lock it down to the
ear right
but this is not this is not one of them
this is not
meant to give you a date on january 1st
2022 you're going to walk out no this is
saying that you're going to be in
bondage for a period of time
approximately 400 years more or less
um
and then uh you will be delivered but
it's not uh an exact uh time frame well
uh again well i'll let you take it out
down this is this is your program
well our time is up but we are so happy
that you could be with us here
keep sending us your questions
we are also very enlightened with them
actually i have grown more into my
knowledge of the bible with all these
questions so god bless you
and see you next time
[Music]
you